well he's a big dog the st. Louis force
commissioned Frank welcome to the show
it's great to be here I know you get
referred to as a big day I think she
means a Kahuna maybe the first time I
doubt it tell us about the st. Louis
sports commission and the kind of work
that you do well the same with Sports
Commission is the organization that
works to make saying it was a better
place to live visit work and play
through sports we're nonprofit civic
organization in st. Louis we do major
events bring them to the city for the
benefit of our fans as well as for the
benefit of the economy we also have a
affiliated Youth Foundation that focuses
on promoting good sportsmanship and
helping kids lead happier healthier
lives to sports great mission I know
you're doing all sorts of new
initiatives here in st. Louis I heard
about d1 wrestling becoming Emma's we
had with the NCAA the collegiate
wrestling championships in st. Louis a
couple weeks ago and it's the eighth
time the championships were in st. Louis
20,000 fans come from out of town it's a
it's a wonderful sport we talked about
the you know the parallels between some
of the sports that we do in in chess you
know the chess is a is a very new sport
compared intellectual wrestling as well
its intellectual wrestling but you know
chest is only about 2,000 years old and
wrestling goes back fifteen thousand
years they call it the world's oldest
and greatest sport absolutely fabulous
what is the economic impact of having
something like the chess championships
and the sink filled cop and all the
great chess events that are happening
ideas anymore i love to answer that
question but because the questions
usually asked narrowly but i like to
answer the question broadly so if we
were to say the economic impact is a
million dollars i think that really
under sells the actual impact of the
event but because you have to figure in
not not just how much do visitors spend
but but how much how much value is there
for the publicity how much value is is
they
for the intangibles that come along with
the prestige of hosting an event like
the Chess Championships or like the
wrestling championships or for example
we're hosting the NCAA collegiate
gymnastics championships next weekend
here in st. Louis will have 12 by
universities competing for that
championship we should call st. Louis
Championship city that's what Rex always
says and it tells me I need to move this
not because of that any other new
initiatives we should be looking for I
know baseball has started i know this is
cards country exact what else is going
to be happening other than what you've
mentioned well we're bringing we'd like
to bring a variety of sports to the
region and and so later this summer
IndyCar racing comes back to st. Louis
next spring we will bring the
Southeastern Conference men's basketball
tournament to st. Louis University of
Missouri University Kentucky and and so
on next summer we'll be hosting the
100th anniversary of the PGA golf
championship and you know that fits in
around hockey and the stanley cup
playoffs and and baseball we always hope
for the playoffs in october so it's it's
a it's a bustling sports scene in our
region and we're happy to promote sports
at every turn so how much more you going
to support some chess I want to hear my
well we your big chess addition we love
we love chess and we actually did two
spots on chess at our wrestling
championships we have a host who goes
around town and films these spots to
show off st. Louis to our visiting fans
and we did two of them here at the chest
museum so that was a lot of fun and
gives us an opportunity to connect the
initiatives that we're working on
fantastic great work you're doing with
the sportsman Commission and thanks very
much for supporting chest and st. Louis
we love it thank you Frank viverito the
big dog make sure you put that at home
right by the front door
it great that would go over well